I felt so much pain not only physical
but psychic in a way that felt
unendurable and I had this sudden vision
of a wooden marionette connected to
strings to four birds and being lifted I
picked up my paintbrush and I had this
chant on repeating my head I released
control I surrender to the flow and I
painted that painting in one fast
furious breath and as I started Ed to
paint the ropes connecting the wooding
marionette to the birds I could feel my
spine lifting I could feel myself being
lifted and that to me is the power of
creativity it's the power to make
something out of nothing to transform
the most brutal experiences into
something interesting and beautiful and
it feels like a kind of magic